first I ask them if they have a script
there's a lot of people looking for
buckets does this plan before thee I'm
not as pretty you don't have a script
can't make a plan you're making the
other thing I ask them is can you do
what I did because I know how to operate
a camera I know how to teach somebody to
boom I monitor while I'm operating that
camera I'm directing the actors while
I'm operating that camera I'm telling
the two other camera operators also
operating while I'm operating while I'm
monitoring what shots piled on I know
how to mix the sound and sync it I know
how to edit everything I shot so I don't
hire an editor I know how to fundraise I
know how to build audience very slowly
over years so if you can do all bash ask
me for my business because otherwise you
have the business plan that involves
hiring a director and editor or writer
or sound mixer all those people
I don't have those people because I'm
trying to be cheap so I learn how to do
a budget and it took me a long time so I
don't have to have a business plan that
has this salary that salary this salary
I don't have to come an editor
disappearing with my or just
deciding they don't want to cut it
anymore or they can't take notes because
I'm yet on the draft it's so I'm I'm
testing law I'm writing I'm figuring I'm
scheduling while I'm writing
I'm all right how am I going to shoot
I'm already thinking about shots while
I'm writing so I'm already thinking I
don't know who this character is gonna
be he's his character and right to it
please and and write that character and
call an actor and I've sat at this table
right here and Julie McIlvain after I
know asked me who else I needed a cast
for project and I said what the role was
and kind of what the guy was and write
our know Keith Summerall pulled out his
poem Kathy Galacticos a Casio echoes and
another filmmaker pulled up his poem on
IMDB and they're like I know this guy I
know this guy I know this kind in 24
hours one of those actors had seen the
Sheridan script and was cast
so 30 actors no casting director it's
all human it's all that kind of stuff I
think that's the thing is like so people
say like did you work with your casting
director what how did you cast a nice
and I say that's how I cast
I asked I'm looking for this guy in this
guy you know anybody so I haven't talked
to an end of an agent or a manager to
get an actor to be
we have 30 actors now without one
audition I know but no one casting
director without any of that so so if
your business plan is to see a lot of
theater to see a lot of a lot of people
so you know a bunch of people who act
you'll also know about your other people
who act and then you can as you're
writing you can go say I could use that
person that's my business play like it's
my business plan is to write so I can
only need an actor for this amount of
time that's my business my business plan
is to learn as much as I can so I
can shoot this but I can't just go here
it's pikemen I don't think anyone's
gonna write a business plan and say the
audience is gonna build over two or
three years so let's all meet back here
in like three years
see how it's like running a marathon
after a while you're out of
carbohydrates and you're running out of
your head those last four miles you
can't store the type of hydrogen your
body 22 after that it's just your will
and your training and
and I think it's the same with
independent filmmaking if it's if you
don't have that spike in success in the
show business if you don't have the big
award if you don't have that thing that
happens to a lot of people have that big
thing happen and then that is because
somebody else's validation that's not my
business
the audience is who tells me what I do
is good and that they enjoy it
that's my those are people that's not a
company that's not an executive producer
clothes are the keys to the universe who
is telling you based on their resume
how's the world works how your story
should be told based on this person is I
need to do that yeah not gonna get rich
gonna make a little money eventually one
day but should I just keep trying to
sell to the factory what should I keep
trying to please that one person or that
to order the people that say I know what
were the development people who want I
know how dumb it's gotta be for the
readers to get the movie that stuff I
don't want to play that game anymore I
did it's boring I just want to tell
stories to human beings and now I can
now I can tell the story go worldwide
audience people donate money and tweet
Poston and me trying to make it can make
you fat it's a very archaic business
plan but I think it's self system to
self-sustain that more than being an
employee trying to get
you